foreign
249. open the hearing for Hospital 249
for a non-germaine Amendment great
um I'm representative hunt representing
Ridge so what we have here
um is uh we had a we had a little mix up
and and I would say is this is one of
those Murphy's Law when things can go
wrong it it's amazing how it just goes
wrong again and the exact same problem
occurred the first time happens the
second time so
um unfortunately you don't have this
amendment yet where it turns out I was
the only one who got it last night I
didn't think that it was going to happen
but I'm going to tell you what it is and
then we can uh obviously take it up in
subcommittee which we were going to do
uh this afternoon okay so no excuse me
it's insurance so it's tomorrow we'll
take up this amendment tomorrow so what
happened is we'll start out with last
year
last year uh and when I would say last
year we passed something but it had been
an issue that's been around for many
many years which is can we allow dogs to
be on the porch of a restaurant
the way the bill came in originally was
only it was limited to only to Nanos and
obviously that's that was not going to
work that we want to make sure this is
available to any restaurant or anybody
who has an outside seating area that
they would be allowed to have a dog on
the dot on the deck
the reason why this issue had been
around so long and never been resolved
was because of service dogs
and the issue was that if you're going
to if that if you can have random pets
coming on this on the same place where
there might be a service dog there is a
potential of conflicts between the dogs
so over the years we've always never let
me say we've never passed we've always
struggled with this problem of the
service so part of the problems that was
solved by saying okay it's not inside
the restaurant it has to be outside the
restaurant it has to be someone who has
an out the restaurant or or obviously a
beverage manufacturer or a nano has to
have an outside facility and and that's
where this dog's allowed and and then if
you read the statute you can see there
was lots of requirements about how they
can do this and how the dog has to
unbeknownst to us when the Senate put
this amendment in and sent it over to us
they actually instead of just putting in
as a separate Standalone statute they
actually replaced a another law that was
already on the books that's been on the
books for
uh give or take eight to ten years
ironically the sponsor I just saw him
downstairs he happens to be here
representative Butler and uh what he he
had a bed and breakfast and
um and yes he has these
um Bernice big jumbo Bernese dogs and
they're very gentle but that it's a bed
and breakfast and they're in let's say
the bed and breakfast in the living room
there they don't go so they're in the
living room facility and the question is
you know are they barred from using
the uh use it being being there because
of the health code issues and let alone
the service dog issue
so at that time we didn't pass
legislation and it was on the books and
it's been on the books for a fair amount
of years
then the Senate passed this other
Amendment this other statute which was
the loud dogs on the deck
but unbinosa everybody wasn't paying
attention we missed it was it replaced
it
so I realized that the amendment that
was initially sent out to everybody said
uh repeal and reenact which is exactly
what happened the last time
is that they repealed a paragraph and
put something else instead we don't want
that's not what I was trying to do with
this amendment what I'm trying to do
with this amendment is to Simply add the
statute back in so that we would still
have dogs can be on the deck
but we would also allow dogs to the
owner's dog to be in the facility
now this was brought to my attention by
representative below and blo has a very
simple Amendment which was let the dogs
be let them be there well that was fine
that's very simple that's very nice
however Jane you were not around for all
the years that we had the problems of
this service dog and the health code
issues and so obviously I took your
Amendment and I sent it over to HHS who
are the ones who enforce it for
everybody who would not a city in town
for the rest of the states now and I
would say for uh for you said a few
members be aware that we do have a
little bit of a conflict in that cities
and towns have their own code
enforcement health code enforcement you
can ask me a question Jane okay
afterwards so uh that they had their own
code enforcement but in this case to
just unilaterally say that you can any
owner can have a dog it was there was a
pushback
and I said so would you have a problem
if we just took the old statue that got
accidentally repealed and put that back
into the statute books and she said no
problem
they would be happy with that that's
what I attempted to do unfortunately on
the way to legislative Services it got
written wrong it got written as repeal
what we did last year and reenact so
this amendment you'll see adds a new
paragraph
to the statute so we will still have the
current law which is dogs allowed on the
deck but this would bring back the Old
Law
and put it in the statue in a different
place obviously and which will state
that a restaurant now owner can now have
a dog on their property
but they still have to comply and this
is the key thing Jane they have to
comply with all those other issues which
is it can't be in the kitchen or
production area it can't be you know it
has to be removed if a service dog shows
up
okay that's
we that that's what we're you know that
I guess that was one of the big rubs so
anyway so
um theoretically there should not be any
problem with this new Amendment and I
representative
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question
what is the difference between your
Amendment and my Amendment it's pretty
much the same thing your amendment has
one sentence
it is it it
it is already in the bill that was
passed last year the second section that
you put in the what I have is the first
sentence and the other sentences that
are there the next sentence is already
in the bill that was not repealed okay
so again if in terms of looking at the
two amendments the one that was sent out
last week
versus the one that you just got just
now the key line difference is you'll
see what the RSA it's being changed to
you have to look above the paragraph and
look at the RSA change
yeah it's 466.
colon 44.
Roman numeral
two
okay and what's the other one say
three
not yours the other one that was under
I don't know I'm so confused it leaves
Roman number two alone and adds Roman
numeral three so exactly thank you Mr
chairman any other questions
there's no spear
talk to the mic try to make sure the
I just have a very simple question with
all the words flying around yeah if
we're in a restaurant
and we're eating no dogs right
yes emphasize the restaurant except for
service dogs this this legislation would
allow that
um service dogs would be there this
legislation will allow the owner's dog
to be where we're eating in the
restaurant in the eating area
in the restaurant area and a sign has to
be displayed and the sign has to be
displayed before you walk in that
there's a dog there and that if a
service dog were to show up then that
dog needs to be removed
anything about how mannered the dog is I
mean some of these dogs
if I come from a house with dogs so
there's going to be a smell something I
walk in is that gonna am I gonna be
attacked
that's what I worry about okay like I
say this was the law for for a long time
it was eight or ten years it was law
that your the sign is on the door and
saying warning you that there this
there's a dog inside here and and the
sign would say is if you asked to have
that dog removed but in terms of your
concern is that and I I learned about
this because from my rental vacation
rentals it turns out to some that yes
there are some people who are incredibly
allergic to dogs and cannot come into
any space that a dog has actually been
for the questions representative Gibbs
uh thank you
um just
for clarity
um
people could still continue
to bring dogs into outdoor restaurant
areas
that is correct thank you
representative Burroughs
thank you what does it mean when you say
you have to remove the dog let's say
that there's an office that takes the
dog out of the eating areas that suffice
that's suffice okay but the key element
I would say they can't go into the
kitchen
but yes it would go into the owner's
office
any further questions
okay thank you Mr chairman
I think we have uh one pink heart okay
and we'll call DJ Bettencourt from the
New Hampshire insurance department yeah
that's oh I'm sorry is there a card up
here
so these are the owners in Manchester
and all right could you state your names
for the record and if you could fill out
a pink card when you're done and we'll
have that in the record sure thing my
name is Aaron share
um
we are the owners of two share Brewing
Company in Manchester New Hampshire
um
we are in support of uh dogs being able
to be outside of restaurants and
breweries we think that's very important
um however uh we were notified by the
Manchester Health Department that our
Companion Animal our our dog was no
longer allowed inside the brewery with
us uh with the latest legislation that I
believe was passed in April of 2022 so
we would like to be able to bring our
dog uh back into the brewery she is
integral to our company to our brand
our customers love her
um
she is the face of our brand and right
now our mascot is not allowed in the
brewery
do you have anything to add uh yeah I
mean we adopted blue three years ago
knowing she was a rescue dog and that we
would be able to have her with us and so
I don't think we probably would have
adopted her if we had known that we
would have to leave her home alone we
are at the brewery a lot it is our
full-time jobs
um and so it has definitely had an
impact on our customers on us on our
business and on blue
very good
all right questions from the committee
representative Burroughs um just a quick
question same question I asked
representative terminal before if a
service dog came in I presume you have a
place you could put the dog in an office
or something she has a crate
in uh in a separate room that we would
representative billio yeah thank you
thanks for participating in democracy
and good luck thank you
would you believe
all right so you know further questions
thank you very much
and then we do have one last pink card
DJ Bettencourt from New Hampshire
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee this may be one time where the
time I asked for which was two minutes
is less than what I need
um DJ Benton Court Deputy Commissioner
of the New Hampshire insurance
department I'm joined by Emily Doherty
my colleague at the department we have
no position on the amendment other than
we would say good luck figuring out how
to find the right balance but what we
would say perhaps plead is to not do
anything that's going to endanger the
underlying bill which is a very
important bill to the department and we
think a very important bill for Consumer
Protection in New Hampshire
so as you go through this process
remember that the bill attached to this
amendment is very important so keep that
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
would anyone else like to testify on
all right so it's past ten nice home oh
yeah okay
okay so we're doing subcommittees today
and
we're doing the
42. okay House Bill 42 the homeowners
operators
operations
okay
so
okay did we actually it turns out that I
put bills in here we actually took
action on did we already take action on
this one yeah
okay so so we actually exact it already
well what hen was is that I was working
from the committee reports so evidently
the report didn't get filed so I it said
it didn't tell me okay so that was ought
to pass
okay
and and the vote was it and now it's in
the record see that's good now okay 19
zip okay
all right so we're all set with 42. okay
subject
okay it's a 239
uh subcommunity work session
it's actually works no that's a
subcommitting work session
and another exact session yeah that's
today's Executives or tomorrows that's
these are today's
exact session so is this a bill that
didn't get taken care of
ability condo disclosure oh this is
almie's Bill okay
all right
um
yeah
at Japan no it didn't have any Amendment
right 42 2 42 oh yeah yes that's right
we had we did the amendment correct
yeah so it's ought to pass as amended
uh
okay so right now I'm going back to 42
so does anybody have what is the
okay
so
let's introduces and having a moment
because
all right
all right so we will I will make sure
that that amendment is properly recorded
and if not then we'll um we'll take it
up tomorrow but
hopefully that's properly recorded
okay
all right so the con the condo Financial
disclosure my memory was that
that this bill as written was um
I know that rep yeah she put in an
amendment that that it was still
problematic she said she was gonna work
on it on out for somewhere right okay
all right so representative Burroughs
seconded by representative Ammon moves
okay so the subcommittee that's what's
what this is today
the subcommittee is Ammon Cole Thaxton
hunt oops you're not on this one sorry
so representative McAleer moves to
retain
and Herbert peel it and spear
okay does everybody know who's on this
committee and Cole is here he's back
and I think he's got a better Santan
than me but but then again you were
that's right in Aruba all right so
that's amoncol Jackson
hunt macular Herbert Phillip and spear
okay the motion is to retain all those
who in favor of retaining raise your
hand
one two three four five six
anyways
Thaxton I'm missing faction so it's
seven
okay
all right
um
right
okay so this is a bill that I would say
uh on the face of it is potentially a 10
10 bill
a 10 10 bill 1010 in other words it
would be the commit
so I guess I would start by saying is
there any Democrat who wants to pass
this bill
okay now is there any Republican who
I don't know if the bill is quite ready
but
um I think there's Merit to it so
there's a an executive order from the
governor governor that covers the
executive branch correct and this bill
would add the other branches of the
government to sort of be a mop up right
right so you know I think there's
growing concern over how much China has
a fusion economy it's the military
controls yes all of its industry and so
any any products that we buy from China
could potentially have back doors that
it you know it gives China an advantage
um but it's a difficult thing to police
so I mean a microwave
are there any microwaves still being
made in the United States
so so you're an old microwave is a dull
microwave but new microwave is a smart
microwave that's connected to the
internet and then potentially
essentially could tell that Chinese or
tell what you're eating
sometimes I'm saying I mean it's uh
unfortunately the Chinese economy is so
embedded in our manufacturing that it's
hard how does the state how is the state
ever I mean you would need an exemption
for that I guess so it has to be
um I mean you have to somehow narrow it
I don't know what the governor did in
his order
that how did how did the governor deal
with the microwave does anybody know
representative field you have a comment
the the definition of owned in the bill
is too ambiguous to be able to legislate
what does owned mean does own mean a one
percent stake in a company such that a
publicly owned company that is traded on
the NYSC that has one share that is
owned by uh China or the uh the People's
Republic of China is now an own company
uh because of that reason it's
inexperience of legislate because the
definition of owned is is nebulous
um and I also think that there's a
potential supremacy clause issues in
this as well that Foreign Relations is
exclusively reserved to the federal
government and this potentially Treads
upon the federal government's right to
engage in foreign relations uh because
it engages in a supremacy clause issue
that is reserved to federal government
we should also find the new experience
to legislate
fair enough representative wall should
you have your hand up
you asked
you asked what the governor did I think
it was specifically about Tick Tock it
wasn't about Manufacturing
it was specifically for tick tock I
believe wasn't it
yeah we got we had right
you want to read it well it looks too
long to read give us the highlight
foreign
this is from Governor's uh
uh sir nunu
don't have the date but anyway uh now
therefore Christopher sununu I do okay
to preserves the safety security and
privacy of the citizens of New Hampshire
products from the following vendors will
not be used in or connected to any state
Network or installed on a state issued
device including but not limited to
desktops laptops and tablets and mobile
phones across the executive branch
Hawaii technology ZTE hyterra hang Chow
hickvision
10 cent Holdings including 10 cent QQ
wallet and WeChat Alibaba products but
not limited to alipay and tick tock
the department of Information Technology
and other examples entities as
applicable within 30 days develop and
Implement a plan to remove any
referenced Hardware products from the
networks remove any reference software
products from the networks Implement
measures to prevent installation of
referenced hardware and software
Implement network-based restrictions to
prevent the use of access to a permanent
servers and included risks associated
with these Technologies into the
Statewide cyber security and awareness
training program
uh Chief information security officer
will continually monitor an update list
Etc
okay
so I guess that solves the microwave
problem because they've used narrowly
used doing computer technology so
Keith
I'd like to make a motion to retain okay
okay
I think I think retaining is fine John
can I ask a question yes representative
spear
man can I ask
you no you this is
the dod has spent a fortune
and I've worked in this kind of stuff uh
figuring out what they can allow on
their networks and in their equipment
they do not ban products per se they ban
chips
If the product does not have specific
chips in it and they list those chips
they tell you what they are
then you can't have it anywhere in a DOD
product that doesn't mean you can't have
it in your house
I think that
broadly Banning whole products without
looking at see what it's in what's in
them and what they're used for is doing
a disservice to our our state
I agree and that's why we should retain
this bill
okay
so the question is I'm sorry put hit the
red button
this is already covered by Federal
Executive law
in federal yeah I thought Federal was
Department of Defense foreign
did it include state
agencies
probably have laws of what they allow on
there and just as we don't know do we
really want to go through this for the
next week or two I'd say let's just
retain this bill we could work over it
over the summer and then come win next
fall we'll have a better answer to
whether this is is really an issue or
not
but I'm not on this committee so okay
okay
representative until
um I think that we should probably kill
this one because no matter what we do
with this one we're never going to be
able to massage it into something that's
salvageable
that the better approach would be a
company-based approach such as what we
had on the governor's order because no
matter what we're dealing with a foreign
country in this and we can't do that as
a state because of the supremacy clauses
I understand yep so kill this bill
because of the supremacy clause issue
come back take a company-based approach
which is the better wiser way to go
which is what doe e does but
we can't name a foreign country in the
bill because that's you know one way of
looking at is we're teetering on a
declaration of war there and I don't
think we want to do that either kill
all right so I I uh Jackson's not here
okay
how badly do you feel we should hold on
my routine motion is a courtesy to uh
representative Roy
um and I I think he would like to
well let's look at your ranking Democrat
on the subcommittee representative
okay and Herbert wants to kill it so the
Democrats all want to kill it and we
have at least one Republican who wants
is missing today
okay uh so uh the subcommittee wants uh
is itl
but
there is
he has okay you want to re rehash the
yeah so
Rich do you have opinions about the
foreign
you have to turn the mic on and
I do uh none that I want to share right
at the moment
okay
okay well uh all right so
um all those all those in favor of
retaining because that's the initial
motion uh retaining uh
HB 86 raise your hand
one two three
this is the banking condo built making
wait 86 is Ammon Cole Thaxton hunt
okay
okay all right so the vote uh to retain
was
three people is that correct and those
who uh who are opposing to the retaining
motion please raise your hand
five
okay
like five okay so that motion fails uh
representative Philo uh seconded by
representative McAleer moves uh in
and
um
all those in favor of itl raise your
hand
one two three four five
those opposed
all right now on to the next one uh uh
two two five this I have my notes is
currency prohibition but this the
prohibition is against
using
this is the Central Bank digital
currency yeah
yeah I just assumed get rid of it I mean
I mean it's not this issue is going to
come back
okay so but the question I have is is
can we
if if
this is this is uh Banning a certain
currency so if the federal government
came out with uh their own
cryptocurrency
it's okay would it it's there if they
came up with some kind of their own kind
of currency or so it's
digital currency yeah so
I think the intent of this bill is to
address the idea of a central bank
digital currency which is
it seems like it's similar to a
cryptocurrency but it's it's maybe not
it's it's digital but it's controlled by
the Central Bank okay
um
I don't know I I don't know if this bill
is workable in its current form but I
think that issue is going to keep coming
back
um
it's an issue of privacy it's an issue
of being able to
influence people's decisions their
economic decisions
governments all around the world are
looking into doing this
um I don't know if we can ban it
outright but we can certainly allow for
a competition to to happen
um
it's definitely an issue that this
committee should get up to speed on
so it's worth it just to keep it around
to so we can have a conversation about
it or something or that would that would
be my preference okay it's up to the
committee
representative
again I think we're actually running
into a supremacy clause issue here we
don't have the power to regulate
currency
well but this case is
you certainly don't have the power to
dictate anything to the Federal Reserve
yeah so that's what confused me about
this this is the federal government is
going to create this currency well if
the Federal Reserve is is a private
that's right it's a separate entity
right but it is it's a partially owned
entity by the federal government I think
we're running into a catch-22 here but
we certainly don't have the power to
regulate currency particularly if it's a
currency that's minted by the US
government and if we're talking about
Bitcoin here which is
it's not a currency this is not that has
nothing to do with Bitcoin because
Bitcoins currency yeah is to try to go
after cryptos which themselves are not
currency they're uh blockchain let's
call it blockchain they were saying the
digital would be blockchain
but whatever whatever currencies they're
going after here we don't have the power
to regulate the currency doesn't exist
yet what this is addressing yeah but
governments all around the world are
talking about this issue essential Bank
digital currency would it's not probably
not blockchain but we don't have much we
don't have the power to regulate
currency
does the state have
the state does not have the power to
regulate a currency that if the if the
US government were to create a currency
that for some reason were to have a
digital currency that were trackable
we don't have the power as a state to
say we're not accepting a national
currency
so I disagree again we could say that
you know we'll accept the existing
currency but okay so this again my notes
in my memory my thing this is going to
be a 10 10. you know okay so while we
have to
well how do I know that yeah okay is
there any Democrat who wants to pass
this bill oh hell no that's how I know
that what about
that's the next question I'll ask is
there any Republican who would not
support an expedient to legislate on
this bill
that would be opposed to retaining it Mr
Sherman
retain
retain uh yeah yes or no retain I would
we are doing this is a subcommittee this
is a straw poll and we're getting a
feeling of the subcommittee
this is this is one that I would
actually like to retain because of the
open question of law of what power does
the state have over a currency
I think it might be something
interesting to ask doj as to or at least
doj you know actually advisory opinion
would be really interesting do we have
any power over currency
I I think this is a I I agree with
representative Ammons but he said
earlier it's not clear that we don't
have some abilities here and this is an
issue that's going to keep coming back
to us and coming back to us I mean money
and banking is a big part of my world
and part of my experience in education
and I think that if we don't keep this
around in some form we're just going to
have to deal with we're going to need to
learn to deal with this in the next four
or five years so it's we can we can get
rid of it today but it's coming back so
might as well keep it okay
representative spear
I did a calculation and I figured out
how much money comes into the state from
the federal government
it's and that includes 30 percent of the
entire Revenue that comes into the state
comes from federal grants the total in
my estimation based on Medicare Medicaid
uh salaries and everything else comes
out to 8.28 billion dollars a year
so before we think about even thinking
about
doing something to some currency coming
from the federal government we are going
to wipe out this state if we try to do
anything like that it's 8.28 billion
dollars a year coming from the federal
government and we have no indication
that they intend to generate a currency
that's even going to do any of this fair
enough okay
so uh representative gives I I
appreciate that you would like to enter
in but we will be taking that actually
we'll be taking this up in the exact
session and then I would ask you to hold
your comments to them because right now
we have the subcommittee and I do have a
sense that the subcommittee is willing
representative Gibbs what would you like
uh I just wanted to uh support
representative filio that I think we're
treading on the edge of the supremacy
clause here
um and that that can be a serious legal
problem and also uh representative spear
that we're treading uh uh seriously on
doing serious damage to both the state
and the citizens of New Hampshire and we
we need to be really careful about those
things fair enough
okay so uh representative uh amen
seconded by representative Cole moves to
retain House Bill 225. those are the
members of the subcommittee who are in
support of that motion please raise your
hand one
two three
four to retain it five to retain
all right fine six
those opposed
one
two
all right moving right along uh
uh Financial uh H Bill 227 I'm calling
this financial discrimination good point
um
so on on the Facebook I would think this
is a retained bill which one face of it
but I understand so while I'm interested
here is for somebody who would be
opposed to retain uh versus and in terms
Democrats would be itl
Republicans would be
OTP
but the retain is the compromise because
we don't want to send a bill to the
house floor 10 to 10 and take up
everybody's time to debate a an issue
which is never going to get solved on
the house floor
okay
so
you really want to go through a vote of
itl versus the retained yeah just go to
um yes I do this this this vote a very
similar bill in every public and
controlled uh North Dakota lost 90 to
three this is a terrible bill it's
unenforceable it's totally anti uh
business and and it it ain't the Dem it
ain't the New Hampshire way it you you
simply cannot enforce this type of Bill
you can't
that's your opinion that's my opinion
right and I I got more to go on that
well here's here was the question is
is there some way you could write it
is there some way you could write it to
assure that businesses are not being
discriminated against
is there a way you could write it this
particular Bill uh not discriminating
against businesses was last year's bill
this is not discriminating against
individuals let me give you an example
I'm a banker and somebody comes to me
and says I want to invest in real estate
uh in the on the shores of of uh of
Florida
where you might have hurricanes you
might have flooding whatever if I say no
if I violated this bill in other words I
can't take into account the fact that
there might be a hurricane or might or
the sea may rise because that's uh
climate involved this bill if I did that
which is a stupid investment to do in
the first place I'd be violating this
Bill how are you going to enforce that
is that discrimination that's not
discrimination at all that's that's it
if if you don't take into account things
like climate change or or other things
uh in your Investments uh you're you're
not doing a good job and and I hate to
tell people this but ESG is not the
boogeyman that people think it is nor is
it designed to basically uh put in a
whole new green world it's none of that
it's simply a business decision
it's a business decision that allows
investors who've been doing this all
along ESG the term this is not the ESG
build this is about a bank giving a loan
it's to a person or a business
it's the same thing it's it's all in
this big ESG I have to admit it's
someone who has known ESG for over 20
years because I sit on a Family
Foundation I don't remember guns being
an issue 20 years ago
it was at guns for instance
that was not an ESG issue
it's now evidently an ESG issue but it
wasn't back then correct and neither was
climate change back then uh for though
we go climate change has been around all
this time well I could say someone who
sat on an ESG evaluation I remember what
was on and what was not on and yeah so
all I'm saying is this is clearly a
10-10 vote yeah
okay so why do we want to pursue this do
you really want to go through this we're
10 10. Let's Be Be Happy
that we're not passing anything
which we did last year
1010 means
we are divided politically
this is oh this is a totally political
bill in my mind and so therefore that's
that's not waste
the floors time are you know let's try
to be efficient with our time and let's
just go to retained and move on I I
respectfully think that that's exactly
the reason we should itl this bill but
it ain't going to get it out
it's going to be 10 10 and it's going to
do you want that no I don't want it to
I
prediction if you want to have a quote
let's have a vote
and if it's if it comes out 4-4 I'm just
saying
I'm making an assumption about when I
look at a bill and I can see that it's
clearly a political bill and if you not
everybody
I hear that and then and we've been
we've already been flexible on Two Bills
already that we heard two different
opinions that we had people on other
parties say no John
representative Cole's head he wanted to
kill that bill
right but I just want to move the
process along here okay so if you want
to keep you know go through Protestant
vote we did
you know we can go through a vote so
representative McAleer second it
whatever that's what I'm saying you're
going to make a vote we'll make a vote
representative macular second by
representative Herbert moves in
expedient to legislate representative
feel it is recognized to speak to the
motion
I'm not sure if we had a motion yet I've
just made it okay representative McAleer
second by representative Herbert moves
inexpedient to legislate uh I guess I
have two points here first is that we
are a very divided house that we are 201
to 190 X
which means that they are the people of
the state in their wisdom have said that
we are going to be coming out with very
closely divided votes and that we have
had a number of bills that have already
come to the house floor as 10 tens with
no committee recommendation that we
haven't had many bills that have come
out of this committee yet but it's
inevitable that we're going to have 10
tens out of this committee it's okay
we're a closely divided house and the
people the state said that's what they
want it's it's fine now with regards to
this bill I just have a question for
those who are in support of it how is
this not a violation of the Free Speech
Clause given that the U.S Supreme Court
has said that spending is speech that is
what the Supreme Court has said
how is telling a financial institution
that they have to spend in a particular
manner not a violation of something that
the U.S Supreme Court has unequivocally
said
this speech how is this not a violation
of the Free Speech clause
so I I just I'm
be prank it I I thought we got over this
but well I'll re
from what I believe okay and that yes
we are closely divided house yes this
committee is 10 10. and I think that we
will do a disservice
to the house and to everyone if we get
into a political debate on every one of
these clearly political bills
and I feel that the best thing for this
committee to do is pass those things
which the vast majority of because we
know there's some bills that we're never
going to have everybody is going to
agree to but if the vast majority of us
can agree on an issue and have that Bill
come out of committee and go on the
consent calendar or go on the regular
calendar then I think we're doing or the
house a favor and I think we're doing
our constituents what they really want I
don't think they want us to get bogged
down on political debates and political
issues they just want us to do our the
people's business get things done do
them right and you get political bills
which clearly you Democrats might not
like and believe you me when we get to
Tomorrow there's a bunch of bills that
we Republicans don't like
so the best thing to do is if it's going
to be political is for us not to pass it
and that's to retain it we'll have this
discussion again in November
when it has to go to the floor again
but I am urging everyone to consider
this John Hunt rule
I'll call it what it is Jane the John
Hunt rule that is
I am absolutely a chair that can
actually be dictating if you want to
call it dictating that's fine you can
say you're opposed to the John Hunt rule
the John Hunt rule should be that we
want bills we want bills we don't want
to send anything 10 10. we want every
what comes out of this committee is
uniformly overwhelmingly in support of
it and if it doesn't have that
uniformity if it doesn't you know you
know we don't want a floor debate over
some Nuance of something that just takes
up a lot of time it really is not
helpful to every anybody because all it
does is get everybody to do their
political positioning and let's just
pass good legislation that we all can
agree on or most of us can agree on
except maybe the marijuana bill just a
correct
if we retain it and we take it up in the
fall yes does it eventually have to go
to the floor it would go to the floor
and my recommendation would be interim
study
oh so it could stay there forever it
stays in committee and it never has to
get enacted it never has to be debated
wait a minute house floor except if you
wanted somebody once somebody wants to
fight that motion right but that's the
John Hunt rule that John I'm asking you
can call it a rule all right I'm asking
this as a favor
okay rather than a ruling is that and
I've talked to you just it's not like
you this is the first time you've heard
right
okay you would rather have the tent you
well that's the point of the
subcommittee is for us so we weed that
out
okay okay so we have a pending motion
yeah representative Saxon
I I wanna
comment on the role
I think it's a good rule because
everything's political I mean this is
the legislature wow
um the and the point of this is It's a
management decision let's get all this
this is what I'm hearing you say
we there's a whole bunch of stuff here
that we are never going to agree on
there's a whole bunch of stuff here that
we might agree on and there's a whole
bunch of stuff that we clearly agree on
so if we take all the stuff we clearly
agree on and move that out the door
then we can come back and work on the
maybe stuff and then we can come back to
the never stuff but you're doing this
committee a favor because you're
clearing the docket and you're doing the
legislature body across the street a
favor because we can send them the stuff
that everybody can act on and be in
concert in so I think it's a very good
plan a good way to manage the committee
if you care
thank you very much
I think it's well stated yes
representative Evan
thank you just a little history and this
is my recollection but I think it's
accurate we passed a similar Bill last
year
the Senate turned it into a study
committee
in their study committee bill they said
the first named member of the Senate
calls the first meeting and then they
never named a member so the study
committee never happened so watch out
for that trick by the the Senate
um and so I think
uh that kind of speaks to retaining it
and allowing it to uh breathe a little
bit and maybe so this issue is a topical
issue
um in Washington DC the ESG
the the President Biden Administration
uh
put in put rules in place through the
labor department that funds could
consider ESG and the house shot it down
and the Senate also shot it down
uh
and and two Democrats went with the
Republicans to to
shoot that rule down this bill isn't
exactly like what just happened in DC
but the the the topic is current
um and President Biden will likely veto
that that attempt but it's this is a
topical issue
representative mackler you want to
comment
I think it's a mistake to to retain this
bill there's nothing about it that makes
sense it's anti-conservative it's
anti-business
um I I don't want to take the chance
that this could get to the house and
actually pass
because of politics and that's you're
correct that's all this is is a
political Bill and and it's if you take
the politicalness out of it it's a
and and this is the time for you to
express those opinions yes
what's up
okay do you still want to take the vote
on in itl okay the vote the motion is in
expedient to legislate representative
McAleer said by representative Herbert
all those in favor of uh in experience
to legislate please raise your hand
one
two three
and okay and all those are
what we're doing no you're not no you're
not
no okay what I learned from my
experience last week itl means it can go
to the floor and get voted on and that's
where we're going to lose if we put it
in the in is as an in uh what do you
call it if we retain it it doesn't go to
the floor and that's what I want I don't
want this bill ever going to the floor
all right so the motion we're in the
voting mode okay uh those in favor of
those were opposed to in expedient to
legislate please raise your hand
one two three four five the vote fails
at five to two uh representative Ammon
seconded by representative Spears moves
to retain
any discussion on the motion to retain
all those in favor please raise your
hand one two three four five six
now those opposed
all right
all right so the Commerce Committee has
historically killed this bill
uh
every time well actually you haven't
killed it we there have been a time and
I can even in this case where it was put
in by a Republican and she asked me to
let's please don't kill it you know let
me study on it and we did some more
study on it we kept it we kept it around
but at the end of the day this bill has
never passed out of this committee
so is there anybody now I'm going to ask
for consensus so is there anybody who
it would could potentially be unanimous
well there goes your theory no I'm
saying it's uh that's true but in this
case the sponsor was a Republican
oh so then it's okay no I'm just I'm
just I'm using that as a test of how
political a bill is I don't know what to
do but
so but uh if if you think we should
who wants to retain so if we're going to
use representative Herbert you wouldn't
really want to train it
we'll put you in charge of the study
committee
how have you voted on this bill over the
years
okay
so we had one of the biggest in the
world you're supposed to use the mic
I'm sure everybody in in New Hampshire
well I I just want to point out that uh
let's be close to it the Reconstruction
Finance Corporation was the largest
banking uh Bank in uh America during the
new deal because it funded it and after
World War II it was the largest bank in
the world
and it was a national socialist bank so
are you speaking for this this is no
I watch watch Seabiscuit last night so
okay
all right okay yeah yeah all right so
um
uh
representative uh
baccalaire you want
you okay with itl representative Herbert
I'm just looking for who wants to make a
motion who would like to make the ITI
motion
I'll make it okay representative macular
second by representative hunt moves in
expedient to legislate
okay any discussion on the motion
Cena all those in favor please raise
your hand one two three four five six
seven
okay six to one Mr Comfort
okay
all right
we'll be right along
uh 5 20.
so the last time we discussed this bill
the hang up representative Ammon was on
yes
minus the one percent that's the name of
it the number oh it's uh 64. we had an
amendment is that what happened we had
an amendment on this one
yeah because I see the way I sponsored
it it's different the way it was
okay
so uh
um
do we do I have the amendment
uh
Kristen do we have the amendment on
what's this bill number to 520
we have an amendment of The I must
no no I didn't understand I would it
would I would have taken it to
legislative services do we ever do an
amendment on 520
uh
okay it's not listed here what why did I
feel like we had something
you you gave us a handout
okay
yeah unfortunately I left my paperwork
upstairs so I I I uh so
all right
so some people have it right so we have
I this is why we keep producing this is
why we keep it too sick around okay
all right so this what this did was it
changed it
um
the uh
uh if we're going the deposit is not
required to pay such interest at a rate
in excess of 0.5 percent per year and
the depository Bank shall not pay such
interest a rate less than point five
percent per year
okay and so you
so we're entering into a period of high
interest rates and we're capping it at
half a percent interest by Statute So
currently the banking Department sets
that interest rate
um to me that seems like an arbitrary
number and difficult to explain to our
constituents why we're
you know the lower range is probably the
more accurate which is a 0.05 percent I
understand these these accounts don't
you know are worked for the bank and
that people shouldn't expect
uh the savings rate but
I'm not comfortable with an arbitrary
range in in statute that's that would be
my objection
so this sentence that notwithstanding
before going the depository bank is not
required to pay such interest at a rate
in excess of 0.5 percent so that means
they have to pay if if we were back to
the period where I had no interest right
where we were negative they still have
to pay a half a percent is that what
which one's the upper and then but the
bank shall not interest rate less than
right 0.05
right
so that there's a bond so there was a
so you're you're one more apt to bump up
against that and it would get bump up
against it
so legislating almost zero percent
altogether
do I have no don't have the top or
bottom
excuse me is that in the amendment yeah
so then the amendment that was handed
yeah I I I'm sure I sent it over the
legislative so probably sitting over in
so
what what's wrong with the original Bill
where it says at a rate no lower than
the highest Target federal funds well
the problem with the original if you
were here for the hearing the problem of
the original bill is that um it it's a
lot of work for the banking Department
to to no avail at this point but that
that they have to keep calculating it so
they were trying to do trying to
simplify it
uh so you you would be okay with having
your your rental deposit not earning any
interest in when we were if we were
okay so for the parties and interest if
we removed both the floor and the cap
we could live with that
okay all right so we will have
um Amendment drawn up for uh next week
and which will have no no floor or cap
are you okay with that then yeah okay it
would just be striking that line no well
I mean it would be back to whatever just
right your visit go ahead and for
introduce yourself so some people might
not know that you're the bank
commissioner my name is Amelia galduri
I'm the bank commissioner for the State
of New Hampshire so my recommendation
is just to take the amendment and
eliminate the last sentence that will
eliminate the floor and recap the floor
in the cap if you go back to the other
one it'll change the rate altogether
that'll
reignite everything right but we you
will that so the key Chris
the key thing is they that after the
amendment the original bill was put in
that you and I sponsored that the
parties were involved and negotiated
this new new system that is going to
make everybody happy in terms of
implementing the statute
okay but that this um but the Caps
obviously you know when having a floor
and a cap was problematic representative
Gibbs
thank you uh so
the rate would be set by the banking
commissioner correct thank you
so it would be set by the statute right
that ties it to a predictable rate
currently
in one section of the bank commission
sets it and in another section it's tied
to a different rate so this would have
the good effect of making it all the
same rate less administrative burden
um that goal would be uniform uniform
and less perfect
representative action
well I'm curious because you you said
something to representative Herbert
about uh the interest paid on his rental
deposits there's nothing in this bill
that I see this applies only to escrows
this is only this is only a mortgage
right mortgage issue which which in my
you know it's it's a it's a it's an
awkward position because you know some
banks require you to uh you know to do
the monthly payments on on your mortgage
and your uh for your in your taxes right
the big things the taxes you know
property taxes so you know the fact that
they require you know then well you're
loaning them ten thousand dollars a year
at zero you were ABS I would I can only
imagine that they are actually well the
problem with it is it goes up and down
twice a year correct because we died
twice a year right that's in taxes yeah
so okay so uh representative just uh
remind me that is we because we have it
scheduled for exec tomorrow and if there
is a general agreement from this
subcommittee that that's what we would
go for it I will have the amendment
drawn up so so that maybe we might not
have to meet the following week if we
can get this this resolved
okay so the motion would be uh is is
this committee is a straw vote is this
committee okay with the proposed banking
Amendment uh by uh but with striking the
last sentence
yeah okay I'll make a out to pass
recommendation on it with the amendment
and get that out of the way now okay
representative macular seconded by
representative hunt
um makes this motion of this proposal
yes representative Herbert speak to the
motion
the great will actually be
we don't know uh can you tell us what it
apologize I did not look at it before we
came here but it is set if you if you
look on this um
the FDIC website it is set on the
website like you can go look at it I
didn't look at it before the meeting
should you have your computer right open
and it's periodically you can go back in
time and look at it over time it's very
consistently set that's what we really
wanted uh good morning all Todd Wells
Chief examiner with the Department I did
a little research on this particular
index it's the national rates as set by
the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation I looked back historically
on their website to ascertain what the
range of those rates were over the last
several years the data that I saw
published went back to 2009 so just for
an example there was a range of around
0.20 percent in 2009 and then I just for
purposes of our own consideration and
discussion internally at the department
went right through to current so when I
looked at this maybe a month ago in
early 2023 the listed rate was a 0.33
percent and I will add that that was
actually the highest that I saw in those
intervening years between 2009 and 2023
the current
so the FDIC is your uh
Beacon as to what you're going to
okay
so it would be the index yeah so the the
FDIC tracks I believe they developed
this and
um yes is the national rate for savings
and there's there's a bit of a back
story I'm happy to discuss why that's
important and why there's likely going
to be some longevity to this index it's
very important from the standpoint of
the FDIC as an insurer
but it is a consistently set the goal
was to tie it to an index that the
industry and the consumers like it was a
big compromise to find this index that
seemed like the right compromise rate
um to protect consumers but also
encourage a vibrant um financial sector
the uh
um whatever the rate is this is
um as an insurance agency FDIC is
they're concerned with the uh
um uh what's the what I'm looking at the
security of these these deposits uh so I
would the the biggest concern as I would
interpret it from the FDIC keeping in
mind that the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation ensures deposits and when
and if there's a failure of an insured
bank they basically have to step in in a
conservation role to either liquidate
those assets and and or have the another
institution assume that the assets and
and the liabilities right purchase the
assets and assume the liabilities so one
of the concerns would be as you can
imagine so the the federal Regulators as
this also the state Regulators we're
very concerned with capital capitalist
the protection it's the rainy day fund
the ability to margin growth a cushion
to absorb losses
a financial institution that is in
trouble maybe has some solvency issues
has some other asset quality issues
basically some safety and soundness
concerns the FDIC does not want to have
a situation where that institution can
go out and just try to raise more funds
they might have a liquidity crisis so
they would want to raise more deposits
what's a great way to do that a great
way to do that is to raise rates to pay
more than their competitors and those
funds would come would come rushing in
the FDIC sets this rate because the big
reason that they track it and monitor it
is because they they have rules and
regulations that basically would inhibit
a bank that would be in trouble so would
be either less under capitalized
significantly under capitalized
critically under capitalized they have
specific regulations that limit how much
a bank in that situation
can pay above the national rate for
deposit so that's why I say this is a
very important element
taking it to the you know the worst
extreme if that institution failed and
under capitalized institution failed and
they just ran up a whole bunch of
deposits the FDIC is on the hook to
ensure those deposits for up to 250 000
at a minimum there's other other
elements that they can pay a higher
amount so this is the fdic's way of
saying uh you know we we don't want
banks that are in trouble offering more
than a certain margin above the national
rate because they the FDIC could find
themselves in a scenario where they have
to pay out on those deposits as the
insurer
thank you
can't imagine that happening but okay
let's for discussion purpose of that
okay so the motion uh would be to uh
pass the amendment uh with the uh that
was presented with the last sentence
removed
um all those of of the committee the
subcommittee uh approve of that please
raise your hand
one
two three four five six seven eight
perfect
okay
do we don't have any Amendment for this
one right just this one
this is all clean
okay
all right uh representative uh Montclair
and representative hunt moves uh OTP any
see none all those in favor say aye now
the committee excuse me well we could
keep the hands up all right
one two three four five six seven and
because representative move out okay so
o t
p
seven to zip okay
okay this is which one is this one the
five minute okay and there's another one
so we didn't we didn't have that drawn
okay
I know I know okay
all right so evidently
on 5.95 which I assume nobody has a
problem with to begin with
right speak now or forevermore hold your
peace okay
um that there was uh some need for an
amendment
uh
uh so if people have the bill in front
it would be down in Roman numeral five
uh it would delete the
reply and then
um
further down 6 colon 47
Roman numeral two
advisory committee shall assist and
advise that treasure there is no
commissioner
because that was a banking okay so this
again you remember this is switching
from the bank commissioner to the
treasurer and obviously legislative
okay any questions on those two changes
okay so it's on it's it's 647 say six
colon 47.
and down it says Roman numeral two the
and again it just
it deletes the word commissioner and
okay is anybody
have any problems with that
all right so we'll have this amendment
drawn up for tomorrow
exactly all those of the subcommittee
that are approved uh this with that
Amendment please raise your hands one
two three four five six seven eight
beautiful okay
okay
all right next up is
UCC
ium Ammon seconded by representative
McAleer
all right see none those are the
committee who are agree uh raise your
eight okay
and next up 6 45
there was a new Amendment yeah I know
there was a new Amendment so
so representative Ammon uh seconded by
representative McAleer for discussion
um is on the amendment for 6 45 and
representative Emmons recognized to
yeah so
this is another topic related to
digital assets
um a decentralized autonomous
organization there's a there's a bill in
the Utah legislature that is copying one
from Wyoming so I think we would be the
fourth or fifth state if we enacted this
this approach is a little bit different
than the other states
um
I know this is a big topic and I don't
want to get in the weeds too much
um I'll just tell you about the
amendment so we had testimony we had
questions that representative you asked
some really good questions and that
caused a
Bill ardinger who also spoke bill was
the chair of the digital asset
commission he's also been instrumental
in rewriting our state's trust laws so
he's very knowledgeable he's probably
the foremost expert in the state about
our Banking and Trust could be right
um at least in my opinion he's
very knowledgeable so
um this amendment what it did was folded
in some existing regulations into the
original bill
um I could go over those with you if
you'd like um
let's see how far I can get
um
in the finding and the purpose of the
ACT
so that that section I'm looking at page
one line 10. people you go on yeah yeah
we just got this information just a few
hours ago
um I for one kind of enjoy this stuff
and would really like to dig into it a
little bit sure can we wait a couple of
days and like give us time to do it okay
so
technically I have scheduled everything
that was still hanging out there for
tomorrow afternoon to exec it
having said that
we have next week
all right at least a weekend and that
would give everybody a weekend and that
means we would come back next week uh
and but I would just so you know that
our deadline is next Thursday okay so I
would schedule at this point
um schedule uh for the morning uh any
any anything that we did not have get
exact tomorrow and please understand I'm
not against this at all no you just want
the time to look at it
absolutely
I absolutely agree with that
so and then and then so that would be
would have a subcommittee in the morning
Tuesday Morning of all the anything that
was still hanging out there so that
theoretically that we would meet again
on this issue and then exec it Tuesday
afternoon and then we have Wednesday if
we still are the press that he is on we
could come back Wednesday or and then
Thursday if we had to but I'd just like
to ask representative Ammon would you
prefer doing that rather than retaining
it
because this is sort of a race between
the states I think waiting a year is
probably
we'd fall it behind you know um
I understand this is a big issue um
but we have uh the expertise of Bill
arniger he prepared this uh his
PowerPoint presentation he he's in
California on a trip of visiting a
friend so he wasn't able to make it he
had a previously scheduled
so really quick if all the things that
you don't like about corporations that
Capital accrues to a few powerful people
that decisions are made behind closed
doors right a dow is sort of like the
answer to that it's it's more of a open
transparent process and a way for people
to organize collectively but that wasn't
the issue right the issue is you just
want the time to look at it yeah yeah
but I'm just we now we're on to the next
question representative Burrough saying
yeah do we really want to do we really
feel pressured to get this done now it's
fine just a weekend so representative
Gibbs
uh thank you
um is there some reason we have to do
right
I'm sorry Pride that we're we're good
enough we're trying to we're trying to
show show the rest of the country that
this is the place that you want to do
business in you want to incorporate in
this case I don't know if you use the
word incorporation okay but if you want
to create your business and then and
because most businesses are the first
thing they'll say is
Incorporated under the laws of Delaware
or Wyoming or or South Dakota okay so
that's who those are our competitors we
want we want people to say New Hampshire
is out front and and pioneering these
alternative critics so just much like we
did
um B corporations you might be familiar
with B corporations
are you familiar with that
okay so B corporations are actually
designed to be more environmental might
be more social
ESG type companies and that we passed we
were one of the first states to create
the the B Corp law
uh further question yes for the question
um
okay I I understand that
um but
what if I'm I mean this is a very new
area and honestly I find it quite
confusing and I'm sure I'm not the only
one
um
what if there are other ideas that
haven't been thought of and I understand
that a lot of work has been done on this
and I appreciate it
um but what if there are other ideas
that haven't been thought of that might
come up in other states uh if we might
then work on
um you know if we wait a little bit
um and perhaps sacrifice a little bit of
our pride I I honestly that
hadn't quite occurred to me but what if
there are useful ideas that might be
developed that we might be able to use
if we were to work on this next year so
much like UCC statutes which are model
legislation that everybody tries to pass
yes they're obviously there will be
plenty of time in the future to revisit
it and amend it and include that but the
key element was that we would miss out
on all those businesses who took
advantage of some other states previous
and the and that even they will have
that opportunity to mend their statute
to anything these new more creative
ideas or other things so yes the idea is
that we want to be we want people to
think of nor New Hampshire as the
Forefront on these creative
uh North Dakota or so it's going to be
South Dakota was the the banking was
Banky credit card capital of the world
so and then and and I'll be frank you
know way back when when
um I had sponsored the uniform trust
code uh and and
um and the the another was it was a
uniform when we repealed the rule of
perpetuities uh which was a legal term
it was basically it's a trust issue and
um and
it was sort of you know because
everybody was saying well Delaware is
going to do it so and yeah we were able
to beat out Delaware who is the number
one uh state for corporations so yeah
it's it's a battle
um many years many years ago I think it
was a Trivial Pursuit question and uh
and they said they were comparing New
Hampshire uh so which which state is the
most the Swiss like where was the
Switzerland and it was New Hampshire and
I go huh our mountains are not that tall
but but it was again it's a idea of
Banking and Trust and that kind of
financial instrument you know that where
we should be out in the Forefront of
that issue
on the
revisions here since it does address a
lot of the concerns were raised before
I don't think we're there yet but I
think we're getting closer to the Finish
Line you know my concern is is trying to
rush it through and having something
that is not fully baked get into
legislation
so I my concern is trying to rush this
through to to a deadline and getting a
product that we don't fully like I
wonder if there's some wisdom in
retaining this trying to put in an
amendment that fully get us there
and have a piece of legislation that
actually fully gets the job done just as
something that's occurring to me for the
first time as I'm reading it through
what does it look like to pierce the
corporate veil and I'm using corporate
just as a placeholder here which is a
major concern how much do we borrow the
common law of Corporations and LLCs into
this these are things to think about and
how does the common law of LLCs and
corporations which we borrow back all
the way into English common law how does
that apply here or are we creating a new
common law these are these are things to
think about and we need to continue to
flesh out these ideas and I don't think
we do it in seven days well right we
don't have to because it's going to go
I think we I think we take our time we
do it over the summer okay and we can we
get the we get the input of of the
appropriate agencies here and I think
there's some wisdom as well of putting
it to the Secretary of State's office
just as we have every other entity or at
least talk more about why it is that
we're putting it into a new entity
I just don't think there's I don't think
we need to rush it for the sake of
rushing it yeah well I I would not say
this was rushed that this has been
fairly vetted
um I mean I guess I can look to the
department and see whether they have
have feel like they've fully vetted it
or not but
um you know do we do we have a lot of
our town in terms of this being fully
vetted
so
I see that we have members of the
he has to get permission from his boss
jump Huntley for the Secretary of
State's office with deputy secretary of
state so just so you want to explain why
you understand the role of secretary
Incorporated okay and we're speaking to
um Mr hardinger's uh amendment to 645 is
that yeah he's been discussing okay
thank you um yes we have we have um uh
reviewed the the amendment um uh
certainly the one thing that we that I
think is exciting about the bill I
mentioned here is that we're the first
think of thinking outside the box of not
doing what rhyming is doing but doing
something that's unique that's going to
meet the needs of those who have found
fault with the way that um that would
have been done there
um we had a couple of concerns of the
bill obviously you mentioned
interpretation earlier about the sense
of Pride
um the fact that the bill would create a
separate registry of businesses separate
from the secretary of state is of
concern to us I did not realize I was in
here
um that the bill is in terms of the uh
the filings would be done with the uh um
with the um University of New
Hampshire's interoperability lab as
opposed to filing centrally with where
other business of secretary of state is
obviously raises numerous questions or
concerns as far as you know information
availability to the public and
um one thing that um I will speak to
about the the I think the reason the
Wyoming went the route they did is and
using for example the existing LLC law
was because the the the folks up there
had deal with the Practical matters of
how do you deal with the outside world
when you're not dealing with the
internet right if you need to go in if
that would open a local bank account
um the the the the Dow needs a good
standing it needs documentation some
Authority indicating that they really
exist and that the
um that they have them at the
requirements of the statute the statute
is unique in how it indicates that that
was something self-certify if they meet
all these requirements and they state
that they have that now they exist but
the secretary of state would have no
record of that entity existing because
it wouldn't be filed with our office so
that is one concern that they're
thinking that we think that the registry
we have now could easily be adapted to
handle these types of filings and to the
extent that
um that was taking advantage of
blockchain Technology one of the
certainly one of the issues in the
governor's commission report was that
um the state government needs to start
thinking about how we're going to
operate and utilize blockchain
technology and certainly this would give
us an opportunity
um as an agency to play a role in in
doing that so I think that the the
concerns in the bill
um in terms of our original concerns
about issues like findability you know
um
if they are if they aren't registered
with the secretary of state does
everyone's going to know where they're
going to be able to find information
about this business uh and likewise if
they don't meet the requirements of the
statute such as keeping a legal
representative on record
um is there any implications in terms of
whether or not they remaining you know
okay so it was the unit unh
Apper the interoperability Lab at UNH
um
would be the register would keep the
registry according to the statute
there's an issue that uh
the the governance tokens could be
considered Securities and that putting
it in the Secretary of State's office
might cause a conflict of being able to
weigh in you know
I'll phrase this in the form of a
question would you believe yeah so do
you see any any conflict of the
Secretary of State keeping the registry
so thank you for the question
um I don't see any conflict with that
our Securities Department already does
that
um all Securities are required to be
registered with that department but
there's also a physical separation of
people who do investigations within that
same department they don't
commingle within that department that
does that answer your question well I
think he's saying is if when you see it
as secretary of state Register
the implication is that it's as is a
security because you have the security
Division and you're saying well that's
separate it's a security division is
separate but at the same time the whole
invention is is they're trying to get
out from any government influence any
government uh strings attached and
that's why the a non-profit UNH was CR
you know was saying let's have give it
to them so that that there was no no
connections no similarity to being
regulated like a security
um I don't know if it's if this is a
fair comparison but for example you file
a former Corporation you file with the
Secretary of State those the chairs are
securities uh if you form an LLC the
membership interest of that LLC are also
security so right now that that coexists
right now and since being that
Securities Bureau of Securities
regulation is a separate division but um
the creation of those of those
Securities happen by filing a document
with our with our office
okay so go ahead Keith um so that
there's an idea in the Bill of an
accreditation Authority it's the first
definition so UNH interoperative
interoperability lab that's what they do
they they review code and they they have
a whole Suite of quality assurance tests
that they use for networking equipment
and the idea was that they could also do
quality assurance
because the filing is
really it's about the code that runs the
Dow it's the open source code and that
UNH would have the capacity to do some
quality assurance on that code to make
sure that the bylaws in plain English
match up with uh the way the code's
written so do you see the Secretary of
State's office having that capability
in-house at some point in the future
um and how do we you know Bridge those
two things
I think that's a great question I don't
know that that
um was that actually in the in the
amendment that they would perform that
function or that they would actually
just be the registrar no they have they
will develop a suite of tests
um it's
I have to search for it okay so in other
words it's acting as the regulator to
ensure that that it really was the code
was open and was done the way the way it
which is much what the Securities
division does
maximum transparency for the public
right so that they can see everything
that's going on and know where to look
for it right no I don't I don't know
that we would we would eat and again
it's up to the legislature how do you
would Define that but either
um you would say that we would need to
develop it in-house or that we would be
I do want to add one thing to what Tom
said and also reiterate that I think
that's great that New Hampshire is
looking at this
um it's it's going to be coming down and
there's going to be a lot of different
uses from what everyone realizes is the
crypto market now and I think one of the
big things that's going to be coming is
for accounting purposes just in general
um one thing I do want to make sure that
this bill or this amendment addresses
which I don't see in there now is what
the
um the governor's commission had
identified is how how much of
decentralization is necessary to be to
qualify just to register versus with UNH
versus registering with the secretary of
state it does mention in the amendment
that a Dao can have off-chain assets but
it doesn't limit the percentage of
assets that it can have so
does this create a different route for
what would be traditionally be just a
normal New Hampshire company to have a
little bit of blockchain Technology
within their organization
and just register with UNH versus
um
a traditional rep
so it talks about operational and
governmental decentralization
um
um all right
I guess at this point we're not going to
go forward at this moment
um but I still want to give a week to
see if we can resolve these issues
and uh and and make people more
comfortable
so I assume having their blessing make
you feel more comfortable
representative Herbert having if we can
if if representative can work with the
second question nobody has even talked
about okay and might want to turn your
is is a um a new form of corporate
structure that is expressly designed to
handle cryptocurrency is that not
correct
um I can answer that yes you go ahead
and answer that
it's related to the technology that
underpins cryptocurrency but it's not
necessarily there's overlap but it's not
the same thing so the technology that
underpins cryptocurrency which is
distributed Ledger technology right
allows for people to prove who they are
and also interact with the system and so
a Dao is a way to
allow people to vote on actions that
govern
you know say a treasury so think of it
the simplest form would be a bank
account and a question in a chat room is
cryptocurrency going to be involved in
these tracks actions the governance
tokens would be based on blockchain
technology
not dollars not dollars okay so well my
question my point is that we have a uh
a monetary Sovereign Financial system
that's based on the dollar and it is
always been
One Nation one currency
so what I'm what disturbs me is that I
get this sense and I have a high
BS meter that we are I'm looking at a
problem in the future where the uh uh
it's it's it's going to be a private the
you're going to basically
um legitimize the crypto as a private
asset a private dollar that is separate
from the dollar and uh that that breaks
Nation that we have so it could dilute
the dollar it's not being you know I
know there's a digital bank because
we're I we understand our problem
they're a foundational understand your
concerns with crypto technology okay
I'm not sure you'll ever be happy but
we'll we'll work on this think of it in
terms of gold gold news is a private
asset that has value that people trade
right so yeah we don't do that anymore
okay you can use
do you have to turn it into
all right representative uh thank you
um uh okay let me just
um see if I've understood this
um uh this is essentially
um a somewhat different form of business
organization uh that might involve
cryptocurrency or might not involve
cryptocurrency it doesn't necessarily
involve cryptocurrency it's basically a
somewhat different form of business
organization different from the
traditional corporate forum
is that correct
during this week where we review this we
have an opportunity will you take
questions if I have to ask you questions
or anything I can just email you and you
can you'll be open to that kind of
interaction
okay
I've been disconnected okay there I am
um so the way I'm I'm looking at it
right at the moment is that
representative
clearly demonstrated that he has some
concerns uh representative Ammon and
Secretary of State's office will
basically have a week to try to resolve
these kind of issues and
um their proposal from
the secretary of state is that this
entity from UNH would be a subcontractor
who would then delve into that element
of looking at the code because clearly
they don't have that on staff at this
moment and that would not necessarily be
their task and we nor do we really would
want them to go out and hire the people
to do that so that that will figure out
some kind of language how that might
work and and if not then we'll retain
the bill but if we can get something
come by next week then it might work is
that some good Keith
yeah that sounds good to me I mean yes
we could study this till till the cows
come home
um and and then maybe miss out on an
opportunity for our state that would be
my
so on Friday we're meeting with the head
of the
iol that maybe we could coordinate
something for Friday
um sit down and hash it out what do you
guys think
I'm sure they'll make it work okay
with that yes probably didn't feel it uh
actually just a suggestion that as as
I'm thinking off the top of my head
perhaps the way to work out the UNH
repository and the relationship between
uh the Secretary of State's office would
be to in the statute say the Secretary
of State or its designee shall be the
repository and then an administrative
rule appoint the UNH repository as the
repository but this avoids in statute
using a private organization as the
repository but an effect still allowing
foreign
language yeah I think okay and that also
allows the nibleness to not use UNH in
the future yeah exactly it could be
somebody else right
yeah exactly okay all right we'll move
okay
now we go to a whole new realm of the
type of problems okay first up is uh HB
173 uh now this one aren't we retaining
this the toilet numbers and public the
yeah we want to retain yeah retained
okay
all right P fast in carpets 465.
you're going in in numeric order yeah
I'm just going from my spreadsheet that
I did uh late one night just to comment
on this the uh the feds are apparently
coming out very soon with a uh a
statement on pfas yeah it's exactly the
Rainy answer in the end of the day is
that this is a federal issue in pfas so
okay so uh we're okay with retaining 465
okay you guys want to go with 242 is
that what you're wrong
because you all have it on numerical
order oh I see uh she put them in there
different from mine oh my spreadsheet
okay 242 pfas and food packaging we're
okay then we have uh freeze dried we
want an itl freeze-dried
uh evidently I don't know what's I don't
have the same piece of paper you guys
what's the next one after
four seconds
okay so 280 was the last one or then
no
ah
the list I have okay one person please
what is the next bill
okay 242 pfas and food packaging
no it's 280. 280 is the next bill okay
thank you
all right to a what happened is in 465
has already been retained is that what
you're saying you're just out of order
no we can't hear it we've already heard
it
let's talk about 6 45. that whole
conversation
Secretary of State are going to work on
amendment to it what have we done with
have we done okay I'm sorry are we
okay
is it is it scheduled for the exec
tomorrow
how do I have it
it has already retained okay it's
already been retained
thank God
okay it's already been retained okay so
we're down to the last one 280 and uh
representative patusek uh no you can't
do that okay that's right uh
representative hunt seconded by
representative uh McAleer
uh when we moved itl
280 the freeze-dried because uh she did
when she realized that government was
going to be heavy heavy-handed she she
did not want to go there
okay any questions on the Ito okay
oh everybody and the subcommittee is
about to vote representative hunt
seconded by representative macular moose
uh in expedient to legislate on HB 280
any discussion from the subcommittee
we will will
essentially this was trying to allow
people who are um home making
um food products at their house
um essentially being able to grow their
own stuff and be able to freeze dry it
for preservation purposes and so but to
sell it at the end of the day that's the
key question which you know is it was
that they want to sell it so you know
you can do anything you want in your own
kitchen
but if you want to make it available you
you know and sell it then you have to
know you are going to get regulated by
HHS
okay
so okay
any more requested representative
okay so we do kill bills uniformly we
all agree okay
uh so uh for the subcommittee all those
who are in support of the itl motion
please raise your hand one two three
four five six seven eight okay
zip
all right
um yes represent Gibbs
two uh first of all my apologies when I
asked what happened to 6 45 I meant what
happened to 173 and 242. okay so 173
we're going to retain that because we
want to wait till after they have
revised the Boca
and at that point uh we were recommended
by the department to
um then actually delete the whole RSA
which is always fun to do
but but he's we're not going to do that
until after the toilet facilities one
that was the toy yeah okay and then 242
pfas and food packaging and and we're
going to retain that because an
expectation that the federal government
is going to start ruling uh they will
Their Food Food and Drug is going to
have that makes sense thank you okay
1 15.
and I'm doing candidates on the
moderator for the candidates tonight so
we've got to be out of there by two
o'clock
well
I don't know we voted that bill down
last week I think that some Republicans
that understand that it's a
anti-business
what
I think is going on
the Republicans lost a bunch of stuff
last week because they didn't show up
right
they had a meeting influence in which
Osborne yelled his head off early yes
he's been known to kick people off of
committees if they don't hold him as
well so I think when this film comes up
next week if it did come up
I think he would force them to vote the
we can hold it up for at least long
enough to build up some consensus I hope
you're right because I think that you
know Ito but it could still go out I
understand I understand
but uh
but I want to have more time to get past
this this thing where they they're very
I hope you're right
or wrong
the less chance they have of building up
something for it excellent I I got a
whole bunch of articles on ESG you're
right about and all of it I absolutely
happened I mean this is really a
this is just like CRT
no it is
in that it's such a political thing that
you know well spear then would have been
that they would stick it into the uh
budget
if we retain it at least they can't do
that
so here's the question do I stick around
for this afternoon or not
and do I come in tomorrow morning
are you just in the business in the
business one yeah
I'm gonna stick around because I really
care about pdab
about what uh the uh do you have
oh it doesn't come up no that's not on
this afternoon I think we can go home
and then I mean I don't care about any
yeah I really care about these two
yeah
you can't vote on them can't vote but I
can say some stuff you can say whatever
that's right yeah I'm gonna stick around
just because if I hear the inceptivity
is Obsession you give me a better idea
that makes sense Anita I'm thinking of
not showing up until 1 15 tomorrow what
do you think
yeah yeah and I'm not on the this
the toilet on this floor just right
ah I want to empty that second cup of
coffee
foreign
I think we have a light light schedule
here right
all right first is uh 248 memorative
bottles
and we've been honored by having the
chairman of the commission
and
everyone has the handout
um
so
I know you're
you're a busy man
they come over here but
when it comes to uh the subcommittee
process
we we uh we're generally uh
moving very quickly here absolutely so
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for having me
Joseph Malik I'm the chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission and with me
is Chief mark armaganian
we did I did have a handout I know
technically we're not supposed to do a
handout but I wanted to make sure that
everybody understood the 177 colon 8
which leads the historical fund the
language that the Liquor Commission
follows the last revamp in that was done
in 2018.
and secondly on the second page this is
just a quick little synopsis breakdown
on the two pages highlighted in the lime
yellow of the gross profit of all the
bottles that we've done uh since we
started under Governor Hassan when we
started these along with Senator Waters
at the time we did the first uh
rendition of New Hampshire bottles
and we have done
seven to date
pretty much all sold out at this point
and then on the last page is the is the
first CAD drawing of the next bottle
that we were that we're planning on
doing
which is the Cannon Mountain bottle
there'll be more detail there'll
actually be the hook on the top of the
tram that holds it and there'll be more
detail but that's the first one that
they could send me and that one is in
the process of being priced out for us
now and just for the for the uh for the
record we did send a letter this morning
which I said that I would draft and send
at our last historical meeting to the
New Hampshire Brokers Association uh I'm
sorry the New Hampshire distillers
Association it was emailed to Brian
Ferguson this morning as to asking them
if there would be any interest from a
New Hampshire Distillery to represent
the bottle after this
uh Cannon bottle and or at least
allowing us to fill whatever the next
bottle would be with New Hampshire
products so we left it open to them if
they'd like to design and fill that's
fine or if they'd just like to have
someone else design and then they could
fill with their product so we would put
New Hampshire New Hampshire distilled
product in the next one and I know that
26 was a date that was discussed in the
in the committee as to the
250th anniversary of the United States
and have that uh have that New Hampshire
Liquor in that bottle or or prior to
that we're trying to do one a year at
this point it takes between the design
the fill the shipping it takes about a
year to do a bottle so
so I want to be happy to take any
questions that anyone might have
so representative
thank you Mr chair
um just a quick question about the Canon
tram did you check with the governor
first before you put that out
why you want to see a six-seater there
oh no no I just I'm glad that they're
going to be restoring you know the tram
and I think that's was kind of the idea
behind it to the historical nature of
the tram and and all the folks that have
visited New Hampshire that have you know
taken advantage of taking that ride
hopefully they would be interested in
buying a purchasing a bottle yep thanks
thank you yeah based on this picture it
looks like it needs a little repair I
see the roof rooftop is here
wow the first CAD drawings are usually a
little rough I think there was a lot of
okay okay so is uh anybody have any
questions and the the purpose of this
legislation is actually just uh the fund
itself that and how it's a dedicated
fund which is somewhat controversial
these dedicated funds but um in this
case I don't think this you know too
much question that
the Liquor Commission runs on funds
anyways in terms of the different money
where the monies go and in this case we
at least we're uh the history committee
which I am now a member of and that's
how I got stuck being the sponsor of
this bill and uh is um you know is where
the money goes to the hall of flags
which is our important restoration
project so
any questions from the committee members
s or flags and now it's going to the
historic fund well no well it is that
we're identifying an actual Fund in
terms of targeting the revenue okay so
it just it was it's where it's just
moving
pieces around just where the hell the
cash flow what's the funds so
but it just it gives it it gives the
history committee a little more control
over
um dedicated and what they do with the
Monies
so
and um just to follow up on that it will
go to some historic
um
it'll be designated for a historic
purpose it's in the historic fund yeah
so that's what the committee does yeah
that's what's
I only joined it so I can get it go up
take up a lot of time but I just wanted
to let everybody know that many years
ago when my parents were still alive and
able to travel uh they came to visit me
several times in New Hampshire and I
took them to many interesting places
um but one of the things that actually
impressed them the most was the Hall of
flex in the state house uh it is
definitely worth preserving I I think so
too all right great thank you
okay so uh the subcommunity
for two SEC Walsh Osborne's not here uh
Burroughs Sullivan
below and Vincent's not here so that's
okay is uh all those in uh in favor of
fix it okay
I think you should consider though
having something like Stephen Tyler from
Arrowsmith who's from New Hampshire I
think you should have a bottle with his
certainly take that under consideration
representative thank you I have a lot of
other ideas
okay
.
um
I guess am I the only one that has the
amendment do you have the Aiden's last
and latest rendition thank you chairman
I do not have an official copy of the
amendment I believe you're the only one
get myself into trouble here you are in
trouble
so I can ignore that right
you're good so however
I might need you to run over to
legislative services so let's see what I
um
so
okay uh
I got it five hours ago
all right so I'm gonna
you're you're here to talk about this
new Amendment right
that's correct
okay do you have the amendment
I Have A draft copy that was given to
well maybe I actually I actually have
the legislative Services one so I'm
and for a seven
okay
yeah we can do it okay I just sent it
it's still saying sending stay stay
tuned
okay
did you get it
again I know it's I know there's a
there was a period of time where my
email address which is Prodigy
which I like to tell people is older
than AOL
though I couldn't get anything through
the Liquor Commission
they they could send it but it would
something's wrong with our email address
what it turned out to be it was it was
conquered it was the conquered internet
provider
it was they they just they just anything
with prodigy
and the only reason I figured that out
is because I was I was on the board of
healthy kids and they couldn't send
what's that
you have it so do you mind just going
making copies for
oh thank you
is there is it we'll we'll go on we'll
yeah might as well
that'd be great
so pause on that you can stay right
there
don't go anywhere okay so the next one
um is 544 which um I think we should
yes right oh yeah I do have someone who
might have opposition Origins
really
okay uh representative Walsh is that
foreign
okay
all right
so
we have no we don't have a second
well you know what the vote's going to
be right if
okay so uh representative bitusek
seconded by representative Burroughs uh
moves to retain
um House Bill 544 any discussion on the
motion
would you really like me to discuss this
you're that this is your your window of
opportunity well I just like uh hb639 I
feel that this is Ron for New Hampshire
it's not going to bring in the millions
of dollars that people think it is and
I've got all sorts of data it's which I
had already spoken to on the house floor
and so I feel that this is you know the
other half of the bill and I feel
strongly about it as well
okay any other discussion on the motion
to retain
okay seeing none all those in favor of
retaining and raise your hand
one two three
four
yeah that's right and all those opposed
what
uh
because we're missing Vincent or uh
no you you Jane I didn't see your hand
up in the air oh yeah okay all right so
it's five five to one it's five don't
five to one
okay
all right
um Joe do you guys want to talk about
the changes that are in the amendment
before we actually have a copy of it
certainly yeah and thank you Mr chairman
and committee members I'm Lieutenant
Matthew Culver from the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission division of
enforcement and Licensing
during our last meeting when the this
bill was proposed a couple questions
came up in reference to RSA 17923
paragraph four
this is addressing
um
the changes made to when an affidavit is
required and the designation of a person
in charge
since the repeal and requirement of a uh
an employee
to go through the Felon approval process
uh
that rip that legislation had been
previously repealed so this language is
just cleaning up exactly when an
affidavit is required by ownership who
that is submitted to and the process in
which a person is designated as a person
so I realized through the members we
don't have this in front of us so we're
not exactly sure what they're saying but
so we'll obviously wait until we get
that so go ahead for the next piece
great the next section is uh in
reference to RSA 17821
paragraph two A4
and
the original Bill had left out as as the
members may recall New Hampton
in the dry towns of Newington New
Hampton and landaf so when legislative
Services put out the original Bill New
Hampton was left off of that it is added
back into it as a result of this
amendment
okay we talked about that yep
the next section is uh in reference to
RSA 17956 and I will let deputy chief
again Mr chair and as you know with all
these bills or all these perspective uh
within this bill all these prospective
statutes as from inception of this
Administration we have
sometimes tripped over changes that
weren't intentionally made but but ended
up being made in legislative services to
no fault of anybody but they were just
they needed to be cleaned up so there's
been conversations outside the room of
why this has come up now and they're
it's just clean up we're just cleaning
up some of the stuff that fell a little
short over the years
so thank you okay
good afternoon
um again the next section is RSA 17956
this language you'll see actually
um under title 13 we have Provisions
regarding hearings but we are also
governed by the administrative procedure
act which is in 541a
this actually just cleans up confusing
language between the two
um there's you'll see that some of the
language has been redacted and I just
want to clarify so the language that is
redacted is except it's provided in
subparagraph C the commission shall not
suspend or revoke a license until the
licensee has been provided to hearing
under RSA 541a
the licensee will always have due
process this doesn't change the process
of the licensee this doesn't change due
process the reason that we're asking for
this language to be redacted is because
there is confusion with that and with
sub paragraph C sub paragraph C allows
for 24-Hour suspension of the license
without a hearing that is when an
emergency is happening when there's a
danger to public health safety or
welfare it doesn't mean that the action
of the licensee is an emergency
where this has been applied in the past
has been a riot situation you know in a
college town where everybody's coming
out of the establishments with glass
bottles or or glasses and we want to say
we need people to stop serving there's
an emergency happening there's no
punitive action we just need to get
everything under control before you can
continue to serve
in 541a 33
that allows for an immediate suspension
of the license for emergency action that
means there has been an action by the
licensee that is a risk to public health
safety or welfare where this is applied
is the fatalities
so this just cleans up the confusion of
an immediate suspension versus an
emergency suspension it just makes the
license clearer for the public and the
licensee
I'm going to turn it back over to
thank you and that brings us to the last
section which is uh on this document on
section six section six on page two
director consumers shipments of alcohol
and and two New Hampshire residents
pursuant to RSA 178
um 27 B there's a typo there 178 27b
um and last legislative session uh this
particular law was was changed new
language was drafted and what was
supposed to happen was paragraph
one A B and C were to be split out just
like it is here
and paragraphs two through six were to
be repealed
when it made its way through the
legislators
paragraphs two through six were not
repealed out of that legislation this is
just fixing it with the to what the
Mr chairman I believe this was your bill
so I'm sure you're
familiar
Yeah well yeah I am
it basically had to do with the um
the limits on the quantities of uh being
able to be directly delivered to
Consumers right and the reporting
requirements
the limits correct okay
so for the new members
um
actually one of the reasons why uh this
committee now does liquor
is uh many many many moons ago
um I sat down I actually uh I was
getting beer Across America and I was
had to go to the UPS to get my beer and
uh the case and and they were trying to
convince me there was a statute that
said they couldn't couldn't give us the
beer give me my beer and I go oh yeah
really I'm a legislator tell me what
that RSA is well they he had a little
trouble copying that one up but uh
that's what I learned about department
rules and how rules sometimes uh can uh
sometimes get in the way so I I called
up the electric commission John Byrne at
that time
and uh John and I sat down and and he
says you know I really don't have a
problem with direct shipping especially
with beer because that was that was a
beer distributor problem but he was he
all he says all we care about it was
wine is that is that we don't want
anybody to think that that would be the
only way they can get their wine is to
Direct ship it we still want them to
sell it through the commission so so
once we had got over that he wanted to
make sure that no one could you know
that after a certain point you had to
they had to make the wine available to
the commission then we were we were
running and uh so we were one of the
pioneer states to have allowed direct
shipping allow California wines to come
to New Hampshire
and uh and much so that I I went to the
ncsl conferences and the the uh the way
the wine the wine Coalition they kept
they used my bill they were promoting it
trying to get all these other states to
to take on the same concept
and uh and then when I got back to New
Hampshire that at that time uh the new
speaker Donna scitec says you know John
I think maybe she wanted to get rid of
the regulated revenues committee so she
said I think the Commerce Committee
should have should have had the liquor
laws and uh and then we go running
um and that was I'll find it any for
many years we brought in a fair amount
of money over the years and then uh when
covet hit uh the issue again now came up
is what about in-state and whether
somebody should be able to get the wine
or the liquor or the beer sent to the
directly to their home and that's what
this statute is for this is sort of the
and I I did get my beer from the UPS
but I don't know beer Across America are
they still on the list are they still
they still do business are you we still
could do beer across America
the only uh care they have to be like a
licensed carrier so UPS FedEx and FedEx
for the delivery but I'm saying is they
still a vendor with our direct shipping
loan there's 1390 of them now so I I
would have to check on that which is a
Marvel when you think about that that
all these entities 13 you know are are
signing up to uh to to ship into New
Hampshire
um and you know you have someone you
might walk into a winery in California
or New York or somewhere and actually
not New York right then New York still
that was the Graham decision they were
correct New York but it has been
tremendously successful yes
I think it's over a million dollars a
there you go there you go
what what is the process I'm just kind
of curious now because I was uh in Texas
back around Halloween time and I went to
this farmer's market and it was like
this
amazing wine they were giving those
samples to and he's like yeah we'll ship
it to you and I told them listen to him
we can't ship to New Hampshire
so is that not accurate or do they have
to go through some process thank you for
the question uh representative and yes
they have to go through the licensing
process so for out-of-state
manufacturers out of state wineries they
would apply for a direct shipping permit
directly through the state of New
Hampshire
upon issuance then they would be
authorized to utilize a carrier to
Direct ship that product directly to a
what's the cost for the like that
license
it's a it's on a tiered
um structure based on whether you're a
retailer or a manufacturer
um
I I don't know that off the top of my
head but 220 it's not much correct yes
it's very recent and then if you only
ship once I don't know if that was still
still in the statute but if you could
get your money back if you only make one
shipment that's correct you do so
yeah yeah that I think I negotiated that
when we did uh putting names on kegs
keg registration The Keg registration I
was able to get get that if you're if
you were it was a one-off
then they could get their money back for
the actual registration
so but they still have to collect the
John Hunt Memorial eight percent tax yes
they do
on a monthly basis due by the 15th
so
okay any questions from the committee on
to answer your question specifically
representative the wine manufacturers
pay a hundred dollars uh for the permit
fee the importers retailers and
if I wanted somebody else
question yep for the question so if I
wanted that guy from Texas to ship me
his wine he'd have to pay a hundred
dollars but he'd only ever shipped it to
me then he'd get that hundred dollars
back
if he's only making that one shipment
correct as a wine manufacturer that's
but it's hard time to convince people
things like that you know yeah yeah
there's a lot for that what
trust me trust me
okay uh so for the subcommittee all
those uh in favor of the amendment for
HP 407 please raise your hand
one two three four five six okay and not
all right we're all good
foreign
we're not going to be meeting Tuesday
at this point we only have one bill that
we know we need to take up which is the
uh
and tomorrow is just in the afternoon so
tomorrow uh morning is the insurance
oh the insurance correct yeah and I'm
but that's Insurance health and property
yes you are you are
and then tomorrow afternoon we'll try to
exec everything except that one bill
unless they can pull a rabbit out of the
what time does that start because I
don't have that it's ten at 10.
just the afternoon
uh is that what time that I have
scheduled
115.
right
no it won't be in this room it'll be in
the Commerce
yeah the only reason we're here is
because Monday Tuesdays is science and
technology as the committee room
so
um
hopefully but I will have to schedule
and get you know because we have that
one bill
what happens right so but I by Thursday
we have to have everything out of
committee
okay
foreign